foreign
[Music]
thank you so much for being here
congratulations on a beautiful movie
um whenever people's accomplishes either
of you I actually love to start at the
beginning and ask what was your first
job in this industry you know before you
were a filmmaker were you a PA or when
was the first time you felt you could
call yourself an actor your first acting
role uh well I grew up making um skate
videos so just kind of skating around
with my friends and then we would we got
into doing dumb stunts like we would set
up like there was this one really
special clip that I had where I jumped
off of a mini trampoline into a dumpster
um and I caught but you know in doing
those things which which really is
essentially what Jackass was which it
felt like that was so attainable to like
a young teenage kid who was
you know just wanted to do everything
DIY so
that was like
something I felt like we could do and I
always had an affinity for a camera so I
mean my first start I guess would be
like filming skate videos and
yeah and how old were you
I was probably like a like 12 years old
running around with a big camera
like I mean I like my first camera was
the one with like the actual size of the
VHS tapes that went in it and then
um I got I went to a pawn shop and
traded a bunch of like clothes and other
little knickknacks and got um the one
with like the mini DV tape and then it
went from mini DV to digital yeah I mean
I've been filming my whole life to be
honest and you still have that
do-it-yourself Spirit that's what I love
yeah totally totally
Tim for you uh when I was in high school
I had a party and my mom found out and
grounded me and I watched Casablanca
because I couldn't go out so all I could
do was rent movies I watched Casablanca
and I was like Wow and it just turned me
around completely my first job in the
industry I was a PA oh yeah yeah I was a
PA for commercials because the only
person I knew was a commercial producer
and I did a vagistat commercial where I
drove I drove the garbage truck
and on the highway back from set my I
didn't close the truck the right way and
the garbage was falling out all over the
road so I I knew I had to be a director
and not a PA and so I you know I I went
on making short films and and and and
went from there and I bet you're always
nice to your Pas because you've been I'm
totally nice to my PAs because I think
the Pas are like the heart of the entire
production you know and I don't mean
that they you know doing menial jobs I
mean their Spirit if their spirit is how
AI then everyone's spirit is high and
that's the important part if your crew
is if your crew believes it's their
movie too it's their movie and they try
that much harder I I do want to just
take a second there is crew in the
audience tonight I just want to thank
them
well again congratulations on on a great
movie I know you previously worked
together on the last sun and which
Coulson played a very different role
that was like a 19th century bank robber
I'm kind of curious at what point did
you start discussing that what would
become Taurus
well we were smoking a joint and Tim's
uh in Tim's cabin
except there wasn't a cabin we lived in
this um
this town that's owned by I guess like
Marlborough and they built this Ranch in
the middle of Montana and
the houses that we lived in like I lived
in the barber shop
and he lived in like the bank like all
it was like there was like a set and
then in the back of the set was a bed
and a bathroom and stuff and so I lived
in the The Barbershop was
was my hurt and his uh he was in the
bank and I walked over to the bank and
we chilled one day and we were uh just
talking and kind of getting to know each
other on a deeper level outside of work
and um
because we kind of had like similar
taste to a lot of things and we were
like finding a lot of commonalities and
then we hung out and then that night he
was like
if you ever make a movie about your life
you should let me direct it that is not
how I sounded
that's what I said but I wasn't like
um but uh you know he plays a bank
robber in that movie but but you know he
immediately
we immediately kind of understood that
it wasn't just a Billy the Kid but it
was an abandoned child and he was more
than excited to play both those roles
the kind of slick cowboy who twists who
like spins his gun and also the the kid
who's abandoned who doesn't doesn't know
why his mother doesn't love him and and
that really excited me because it made
me realize he he wants to go deeper yeah
and and that's why I knew like to go as
deep as possible you know a movie about
a musician who's
you know basically uh you know an alter
ego of him would take a lot of Courage
but also it was clear that he wanted to
do it so that's I just felt like
uh not presumptuous being able to say
like listen if you want to do a movie
about yourself like I want to do it and
I went home and wrote a script in three
weeks and sent it to him wow
yeah and it was always the movie I
wanted to do my whole career as an actor
I always kind of
I was lacking confidence every movie
that was coming out that I was in I've
been in being like I really want
everyone to see it because I felt like I
wasn't
either like you know first half of my
career in that department it was like I
wasn't focused enough and it was even
though I was working really hard to get
the roles like I was never getting yeses
I was always getting node and auditions
and continuously pushing and thinking of
crazy ways to get the role which would
end up getting me the role but
um the actual like you know I wasn't
I I don't know it was
there's this one scene um in Glengarry
Ross where Alec Baldwin has this
five-minute monologue and that's his
only appearance in the movie and he
really just makes like he's the most
memorable character just in that one
five minutes and
I never felt like the five minutes or
ten minute screen times that I was
getting in these movies like I was
making that I was having that moment and
so I was really looking for a director
to put me in the film like in a whole
film and really have let me have a
character Arc and this was that first
movie for me that felt like
um
I finally got a moment to act but
ironically the character is essentially
me so out of the fuck who else you know
yes and no yeah I mean I I want to make
a point just say this is a work of
fiction and it's a work of fiction
because I wrote it and it's fictional
but more importantly like I don't think
people understand the idea that it's
performance he's not doing cocaine in
those scenes he's not I mean he that's
not his real assistant there's a craft
service table right outside the camera
this is all an incredible performance
but it's at the same time
close as close to a documentary as
you're going to get in this kind of
level so it's it's it's a really
multi-layered performance that I think
you know people compare this movie to
Last Days Like Us Vincent which I you
know we watched and I you know I I love
but this movie isn't like that movie
because of various reasons one of which
is Kurt Cobain didn't play Kurt Cobain
right and I think it's incredibly it's a
testament to to coulson's nerve but also
his ability to to be authentic at the
same time doing sheer performance and
and and that's why one of the reasons
the movie is so special because it's
hard to categorize and any after I've
spoken to has said it is harder to play
something that's closer to yourself than
to just play a character because it is
so exposing and I mean did you ever
hesitate did that did that thought ever
enter your mind that you know this this
was going to be a tough role for you
yeah I mean every time like um I tried
to get Tim to cut the me yelling at this
at my assistant scene out
um
moments like that you know where I was
like oh it's
I'm just being seen in this way or it's
too close to home or what if people
think this about me and then it I was so
glad that he ended up just
you know keeping it because it
the hardest part
is to be
that vulnerable otherwise it still feels
like
um
music propaganda which is what they do
with all the these artists you know
which is like clean them up and present
them to the world in perfection
and I that like kind of
rubs me the wrong way even if I see
myself doing that you know I was like oh
that's just not I always talk about that
when I'm like on a red carpet and I
I'll crack a smile or something like
that and I'm like ew I don't feel like
smiling at all right now but I'm doing
this because I don't want to seem
ungrateful to the people watching that
are like oh we got you here because you
know my fans are really the reason why
I'm at where I'm at I'm not this like
extremely I definitely wasn't earlier on
my career like at this marketable
you know
superstar that makes number one pop
songs I was never you know I was I
wasn't an easy pitch it was really the
people who like kept Lifting me up to
get to this point to where people like I
couldn't be ignored by the industry
because the people
um
tell me so yeah I mean to be
vulnerable to that extent where you can
be looked at like an asshole or um
[Music]
we have but beyond flawed like I it's
especially like his relationship with
the women in his life is like he scares
everybody away because he doesn't feel
worth being loved because whoever was
supposed to love him
like that that Primal carnal feeling
where you're like oh my parents you know
whoever was supposed to love him didn't
love him so he immediately just rejects
everybody and that rejection comes in
like anger and he can
you know be
scary and that's
like rough to
show yourself in that way but
um
I'm glad I did it and rough to do those
scenes because when you're acting your
body doesn't always know the difference
you're still putting it through
traumatic events I mean how do you sort
of take care of yourself when you know
that you have these difficult days do
you have a do you take your work home
with you or do you have a way to sort of
decompress at the end of the day
yeah I think
I think my girl is having a rough month
that time we were shooting that movie
but no I think I'm just kind of like
that a lot you know I don't know I
I've just lately I've just been smoking
a lot of cigarettes that's been like
just kind of giving my hands something
to do and my mind something to do
anytime I'm
too frantic or anxious and
I I got um
I got a I have a like this this fear of
like
um
these things not being here tomorrow you
know like oh what if this is my last
Film Festival I'm I'm at what if this is
you know I I feel like everything's
always fleeting or running away so
um I've just been trying to love myself
for
myself and not like any of the
things that I put on my focus on
because at the end of the day like
I'm
I live obsessing over the creation that
is Machine Gun Kelly but like I gotta
wake myself up at some point too you
know
Tim I'm thinking you obviously have an
expert in this world and an expert in
this character at your disposal so I
know you wrote a draft very quickly but
then how much collaboration was there
between the two of you and you know sort
of getting that final script and
bringing the this character to life well
I mean I I
I think some I mean I I think Coulson
would agree that we're an odd couple but
there there's there's some kind of link
that we have so the things that I wrote
In The Script which I didn't know about
his life had actually were had happened
to him he had experienced so we had this
really connect incredible connection
where he read the script he was like
this is this is me and
um so we were off to a good start but
what Coulson brought to it first of all
the the the most important thing a
director a writer director does is the
director has to divorce the writer as
soon as the first draft is accepted and
and and you know the producers accept
what you're doing and are behind you
which we you know we had supportive
producers and financers who allowed it
to to to evolve uh during production but
the most important thing is that you
know I I wanted authenticity he demanded
authenticity so there were scenes that
especially the music stuff where where I
wrote what I thought would work and he
said no no no this is really important
we have to do it this way and I'm not
married to the writing so I'm like let's
do it this way let's let me learn so the
next scene I could be like oh if it's if
we're doing this then maybe this will
work or that will work so it was a very
collaborative process
because we were both open to it we're
both open to each other's ideas and I
think that's the most important thing
you don't bring a script to life you
make a film it's two different things
and if everybody's on board with that
including your crew including your
producers but most you know most
importantly you're you're you're you're
most uh close creative collaborator uh
which was Colson you know it it the film
grew yeah and that's that's what's
really exciting to me because it's
organic the performance the film feels
like it's growing rather than being
constructed the the whole film is scored
off of just the chords that I play in
the studio in that scene when he's
making his last song
so Tim let the camera roll for like 30
minutes and I just played the chords
like I I forgot the camera was there and
I was just kind of just
um
making this sample of the Blue
Foundation song Eyes on Fire
and because I was like oh this would be
a cool song to use for this film and
um
that became the whole script so like it
all like
it's it's wild to re-watch
and think like wow that was such a
it's crazy that four chords just power a
whole hour and a half and then
I really like how in the studio
um because every every music movie I
always see like they're always like
sees over thought Studio moments and
while I like understand that in Elvis's
day probably there was like a lot of
like people like adjusting all these
things and like moving them this movie
was like they were recording a lot of
the times just in the room with each
other or like we were using voice memo
to record guitars because a lot of times
that is just how
this generation is doing it and I think
it's a cool Time Capsule for
our our generation's way of making music
you know because it is a little like I'm
tired of seeing the same Studio seeing
in music movies it's
and like it's acceptable when it was
that when it was that but it's like it's
a new time and so it's actually cool how
um
even the choice I brought this to Tim
um when we you know most like rock star
movies like there's like the the drug
like it's like it's always like cocaine
or pills and while both those were still
present in this one there was the he was
doing he was doing whippets and like
that was like something that I'm glad he
trusted me with because it also you know
kind of added
a more now feeling too because it was
just something that
separates it from maybe like the 90s or
the 80s and I mean they were probably
doing it back then either but I wasn't
alive to know so yeah but it I think
it's also like it it the whippets were
you know I think for me he was like in
the script he was doing bumps or
something but the whippets come across
as almost sadder yeah yeah and and
that's what it brings so when you go and
you have that Excursion into the
stand-up comedy part and then you come
back and he's just passed out there uh
on whippets it's almost just it's it's
worse it's it's pathetic
and and it sets you up in a way that
that I think just doing a couple of
lines wouldn't have wouldn't have done
but you know that's Colson coming to me
saying he should do whippets and I'm
saying all right let's do it let's let's
do it well that's that's such great
authenticity you have like somebody very
authentic for sure
yeah I mean but it's you don't if an
actor had been in this role yeah then
they wouldn't have brought that to me
they would have been like okay that's in
the script or they would have maybe had
ideas but like you have this
use this musician this rock star this
person who's living this life
it's it's up to me to kind of get out of
the way like a lot of directing is is
coming up with an idea talking about
that idea setting the stage and then
getting the fuck out of the way and and
you know directing is not about
micromanaging it's about uh it's it's
it's about empowering and so to that
point
remember when you asked for like a great
voice and I was like oh my friend has
this great voice and
Naomi is a friend of mine and she ends
up being in the are you here yeah yes
all right
foreign
she's incredible
but that was like Tim just having
just a real set of balls to really trust
like those suggestions being
well I I loved how this movie captured
the creative process because like you
said you see the same scenes in movies
where like you know there's a studio
executive or a music guy who says you
know we need one great song and that
yeah that was totally in the script too
yeah what's what's really what's really
interesting is that was in the script
and Scoot McNary was was cast as the guy
and he was like great and he came on set
and Coulson was just so hated the scene
so much he was so mean to scoot to the
point where it was like he was in
character but it was also just being
like he didn't want this scene he didn't
want the scene and so finally I was just
like all right well what what can this
guy be if he's not your produ he was
supposed to be the producer and I was
like can't he be the studio executive
he's you're he's obviously your enemy
right now can he be your enemy in the
movie and Coulson was basically yes I
went and wrote some pages and that's
where we get the outdoor scene where it
really works and and it's more again
it's more authentic I love that you
called BS on that scene because we've
seen it a million times
I really want to touch on the cast
really quick because this is such a
fantastic Ensemble and you actually
cited my favorite scene where he's
yelling at his assistant and I just
think that Maddie Hassan Hassan
she's phenomenal where where did you
find her and was there this may sound
strange were there was something like a
chemistry read between the two of them
no it was hard to you know when
coulson's with you he's completely with
you but he has a rather busy schedule so
when he's not with you it's sometimes
hard to hard to get a chemistry read but
uh we we had some
um a lot of actresses audition including
actresses that you've seen a lot in
movies and TV who really wanted the role
because the role Real the movie is
really about their relationship and
Maddie
um she sent in a tape and she was just
exactly who I thought
the assistant was and and she said the
thing that got me perfectly was there's
a line in that during the fight where
she it says God I hate you and a lot of
the actors were reading it like God I
hate you and she said it as one word God
I hate you and I was like she knows what
I'm talking about and then she came on
and she's just such a genuine person and
such so like we're all in like all I
want to do is go all the way obviously
Coulson goes all the way and she was
there to meet us and that's what she
wanted to do more than anything so she's
yeah she's a real fantastic a great
actor and I gotta be honest like scoot
then said okay I'm not I'm not the
producer I'm the studio executive and
these are my new lines I need and he got
it so and I do want to shout out Naomi
Wilde who's who's here and whose voice
is only part of her
I mean I don't know how much acting
experience she had but we got in the car
and I was like okay you gotta cry we
gotta see that tear and you can't I
can't do that on camera like I could
never do that and she
she cries every time I see that scene it
makes me want to cry for her
um and so the talent was was not just
with Maddie not was with scoot or Ruby
but but Naomi is a huge part of the
picture and a huge part of the emotional
part of the picture I can't do any of
that it's actually almost unfair that
the two of you are so good at so many
things is there something you're not
good at that would make me feel a little
bit better about myself
no
I knew it
um I suck at hacky sack I tried a lot
yeah I can't get that goddamn bean bag
to just stay in one place I'm excellent
at hacky sack I knew it
um I do want to remind people that this
movie will be uh in theaters and On
Demand November 18th please spread the
word um it's because it's such a special
film I just want everyone to know I want
to thank you for being a great audience
thank you both so much for being here
today thank you for doing this thank you
thank you so much
[Music]
I'm in the studio trying to get these
two songs from the film to
um release those in time for the movie
so maybe we'll have some new music soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign